many many many many more hundreds of
eggs are fertilised than become humans
eggs get fertilized and by that I mean
sperm get accepted by OVA a lot but
that's not all you need you have to
attach to the uterine wall the inside of
the of a womb a woman's womb but if
you're going to hold that as a standard
that is to say if you're going to say
when an egg is fertilized it's there for
all has the same rights as an individual
then who are you going to whom are you
going to sue whom are you going to
imprison every woman who's had a
fertilized egg passed through her every
guy whose sperm is fertilized an egg and
then it didn't become a human if all
these people failed you
it's just reflection of a deep
scientific lack of understanding and you
literally or apparently literally don't
know what you're talking about and so
when it comes to women's rights with
respect to their reproduction I think
you should leave it to women it's really
you cannot help but notice I mean I'm
not the first guy to observe this you
have a lot of men of European descent
passing these extraordinary laws based
on ignorance I'm sorry you guys I know
it was written or your interpretation of
a book written five centuries ago 50
centuries ago makes you think that when
a man and a woman have sexual
intercourse they always have a baby
that's wrong and so to pass laws based
on that belief is inconsistent with
nature I mean it's hard not to get
frustrated with this everybody and I
know
nobody likes abortion
okay but you can't tell somebody what to
do I mean she has rights over this
especially if she doesn't like the guy
that got her pregnant she doesn't want
anything to do with your genes get over
it especially if she were raped and all
this so it's very frustrating on the
outside on the other side we have so
many more important things to be dealing
with we have so many more problems to
squander resources on this argument
based on bad science on just lack of
understanding it's very frustrating you
wouldn't know how big a human egg was if
it weren't for microscopes there weren't
for scientists who medical researchers
looking diligently you wouldn't know the
process you wouldn't have that shot the
famous shot or shots where the sperm are
bumping up against the egg you wouldn't
have that without science so then to
claim that you know the next step when
you obviously don't is trouble when you
okay let me do that again
let me just pull back at some point we
have to respect the facts recommending
or insisting on abstinence has been
completely ineffective just being
objective here closing abortion clinics
closing not getting giving women access
to birth control has not been an
effective way to lead to healthier
societies this I mean I think we all
know that and I understand that you have
deeply held beliefs and you want to and
it really is ultimately out of respect
for people in this case your perception
of unborn people I understand that but I
really encourage you to look at the
facts and I know people are now critical
of the expression fact-based
but what's wrong with that so it's
really encourage you to not tell women
what to do and not pursue these laws
that really are nobody's best interest
just really be objective about this we
have other problems to solve everybody
come on
come on let's work together